now part two
even just looking at it makes your head
hurt a little bit right they do give you
a clue
they say considering a geometric series
right can you evaluate this limit and by
the way don't forget
this is a part one and a part two right
so you are expecting somehow eventually
this result will appear somewhere in
here right
so even though clearly it's not obvious
you you always have to have that in the
back you might what are you looking for
okay
right so let's give this a go first
we'll start with the gp the gp is just
the numerator right so i'm going to say
the numerator
is now it's a gp and i know the three
features of it that
um comprehensively define a gpa right
that's the first term
the ratio and then how many terms right
so what's the first term
it's e to the power of one on n that's a
bit awkward but fine okay what's the
ratio
what what do i multiply by as i go from
one term to the next
it's also e to the one on n right
can you see that
because index laws right index laws
to multiply this to this right or if you
like divide this by this or divide this
by this this is what you're going to get
out are you happy with that
watch out okay how many terms are there
n terms that's nice i i prefer to say n
terms rather than n equals m because i
think that's
that's confusing okay great so therefore
i've got a r and m
i can say
the numerator is equal to and then i'm
going to pull out my sum of a gp formula
okay so
let's give this a go um it's the first
term it's a
then i've got r to the n minus one right
r to the m
r again what's out of the n
index thought index clause it's just
going to be e right that one over n
times n so i'm just going to get e okay
there's my r to the n
uh minus one all over what's on the
numerator the denominator
it'll be r minus one since this is r d n
minus one right so i've got this
sure all right fine so there you go
there's your numerator so therefore what
i'm actually evaluating the question is
um the limit
as n approaches infinity of there's my
numerator
all over
and then i divide everything through by
n so if i divide this by n the n just
kind of jumps onto the denominator is
that okay it just kind of sticks on you
are you happy with that so far okay so
what we've done is we've considered the
gp got rid of the gp now
and then you look at this and think
right
now
i told you this is a multi-part question
okay so
is there anything here anything
that bears any resemblance to part one
now you have to stare pretty hard i
admit that's what makes this a last
question type question okay
hmm
now to make it a little bit easier for
you in case it's not jumping out at you
right um this is a limit right it's a
limit with regard to m okay so the ends
need to stay in here but not everything
has to do with n right there's some
stuff i can pull out because it's not
that important what can i pull out
i could put e minus one right it's just
a constant so e minus one out the front
okay which leaves me with
whoops sorry um e to the one on n
and
minus one okay
so this is a bit tinier now you have to
stare at this long and hard
and compare it to this now clearly you
can see it is different okay now here's
here's a helpful exercise to go through
right it's different what are the ways
in which is different
okay so you can see that there's
something upside down right this has a e
to the whatever minus one right well
this also has an e to the one over minus
one but it's on the denominator right so
it's like
okay so that's that's a bit weird right
so it's it's flipped
mark tell me about the difference i can
see some others
hey careful touches some obvious things
about this right yeah
good good so so this limit is
approaching zero right
whereas this one is approaching infinity
now there's one other obvious difference
which is that um i mean that's h's and
this is m's right
you have a look this is not just n this
is one over n right there's one over n's
everywhere okay that seems to be the
main thing so instead of um
h
right i have one over n that's what i'm
getting now now look at this look at all
of this
we've just looked and we've seen what's
different between what i've arrived at
and what i'm supposed to use eventually
right yeah can you see these are
actually just three different ways of
saying
the same thing
three different ways of saying the same
thing right
the the whole limit is flipped well by
coincidence
the variable that we're taking the limit
of is also flipped right and then you
compare the where your limit's actually
approaching or one zero and one's
infinity which is kind of
also flipped
right
okay so here's the question i need to
get from here
to here and somehow use this there okay
how can i do it i will do one more thing
which hopefully will make it clear and
then i wonder if you can help me out
okay here's what i'm going to do here's
my e to the one out the front
i've got this limit here
now remember i said to you it's all in
it's only one over n's instead of h's
right with one exception which term
it's that end there right so how do i
turn this n into a 1 over n
if i want this to be a 1 over m instead
of an n right then it shouldn't be on
the denominator it should be actually up
here on the numerator right
so let me write it like that okay um
i've got the e to the one over on end
over here i'm gonna print out the front
i hope you'll see why in a second then
i've got my one over n here
okay
so i've done two things number one i've
changed this n which is on the
denominator to one over n on the
numerator and the other thing i've i've
separated this guy out okay can you see
why i did that by the way do you see why
i separated it i'm trying to make it
look as much like this is possible
okay
okay i'm almost there
i need to do all the pieces now to be
able to use that result okay
so you notice the big problem is that
it's flipped the big problem is that
it's flipped right
actually this is not so much of a
problem
because think about this right if you've
got some kind of fraction some ratio
right and it's approaching one right
well the special thing about ratios that
approach one for instance what's the
other famous ratio that you know that
approaches one
x approaches yes sine x on x right
but we when we looked at this result we
also noticed that
who cares where the sine x or x is on
the top or the bottom it doesn't matter
because you're approaching one
you can put x up here and sign down here
no big deal one over one is the one okay
so
we look at this and we think oh it's
weird that it's flipped
but that's okay because it's approaching
one and only because it's approaching
one
you can just flip it no problems
right it's still the same look because
and only because it approaches one can't
stress that enough you can't just go
flipping limits because you want to
right you can only flip them when
they're approaching one okay
all right now you're ready
instead of one over n i wanted i wanted
h's right so let's do this okay let's
say you know i'll keep it in red let's
let h equal one over m
okay now this has a whole series of
implications for instance when n
approaches infinity
i should write my n's and h's carefully
because they're pretty well when n
approaches infinity
what's h approaching
one it's approaching zero
right
okay so i'm going to substitute this
this is my substitution of what the
limit will be okay so i can put all of
this now
into here
okay let's do it
what am i going to get i'll have e to
the minus 1. this limit is no longer a
limit in n it's no longer going to
infinity it's a limit in h and it's
going to zero
okay instead of e to the 1 on n i'm
going to have
e to the h
okay and then up here i'll have that's
just h over
e to the one over sorry e to the h
minus one
okay right
so this guy this is good this is good
right because i can use this right but
this guy in the way what do i do with
this what can i do
well
if you remember back to limits i don't
know i can't remember if i taught you
this you might have wrote this before me
the limit of a product
limit of a product
is the product of the limits right so
you can actually break this apart into
two limits
i can say it's a limit of this
times the limit
of
this
that is obviously funnier than i thought
why is that funny
anyway okay
the limit of product is the product of
two separate limits okay this is the
limit i was after i finally got him into
the question it took a lot of twisting
and turning but we got there
okay so this guy is going to be one this
guy is just a minus one what's this guy
one this is just me to be h right he's
not he's nothing fancy
here's here's e to the h right and as i
approach h equals zero i'm coming into
this value right that guy there
one okay so you've got e to the e minus
one times one times
one
it's a minus one
okay
um so this is a hard question
it's hard because they kind of lead you
in but it's very non-obvious
how the lead-in actually is useful to
you okay
so i hope that makes sense